- FREEZE, MOTHER[bleep]!
THIS IS A REAL GUN!
IT'S A REAL GUN!
GET UP!
GET UP, GET UP!
IT'S NOT A REAL GUN.
IT WAS A HAND.
IT WAS A HAND, OBVIOUSLY,
IDIOT.
- OH, WIPE OUT, WIPE OUT,
WIPE OUT.
YOU GOTTA GET OUT!
[woman shrilling]
YEAH, LET'S GO, LET'S GO.
- WHOA!
YOUR BRAKES DON'T WORK!
WHOA, WHOA!
DUDE, CHILL.
I NEED TO CHECK THE BRAKES
REALLY QUICK.
PSYCH! I'M STEALING IT.
[laughs]
WHOA, WHOA, WHOA,
WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
- WHAT THE HELL
ARE YOU DOING?
- WE'RE APPRECIATING OURSELVES,
DICKHEAD!
WHOOOOO!
- GET BACK HERE, SCUMBAGS!
- HA, HA, HA!
OUTTA MY WAY, KOOPA TROOPA.
YOSHI COMING THROUGH!
- YOU'RE NOT YOSHI, DUDE.
IN FACT,
YOU'RE PRINCESS PEACH.
I'M BOWSER.
DERS IS THAT BITCH LUIGI.
[horn blares]
- OH!
OH, WHATEVER, DUDE.
LUIGI'S COOL!
BUT LET'S FACE THE FACTS,
DEMAMP.
YOU'RE TOADSTOOL ALL DAY.
- NO, NO, NO, NO, NO!
IF I'M NOT BOWSER, I'M
DEFINITELY FREAKIN' WARIO!
I'M NO BITCH-ASS TOAD.
- I'M NOT EVEN
IN THE SAME GAME
AS YOU BITCHES!
I'M IN DIDDY KONG RACING,
BABY!
- WAIT A SECOND,
IF WE'RE CHANGING GAMES,
I'M PIERCE BROSNAN
IN 007.
[energetic rock music]
HEADS UP.
- OKAY, FINE, I CAN LIVE
WITH ALL THAT,
AS LONG AS I'M WARIO.
- CAN YOU LIVE WITH THIS?
- WHOA!
- THANK YOU.
- [laughing]
YEAH!
- HEY, BLAZER,
YOU BREAK MY 'VO-KART,
I BREAK YOUR GO-KART!
- OH!
THE CHAIR IS MINE, DERS!
I NEED YOU TO BOTTLE YOUR RAGE
LIKE YOU ALWAYS DO.
- HEY! WHAT THE HELL?
- COME ON.
COME ON!
OH.
IT'S THE "ON" SWITCH, IT'S--
[motor putters]
♪
- YAGH!
- ARGH!
WELL DONE, YOUNG SQUIRE.
PERHAPS YOU'D LIKE ME
TO GET
MEDIEVAL TIMES
ALL UP IN YOUR B-HOLE.
- YOU WANNA JOUST?
LET'S JOUST!
- YOU'RE NOT GONNA STEAL
THIS CHAIR FROM ME
JUST LIKE YOU'VE STOLEN
EVERYTHING ELSE.
LIKE THAT DRUNK GIRL, HALEY,
WHO CAME OVER TO OUR HOUSE,
AND I HAD HER!
- WHAT?
- I--
- HANG ON A SECOND.
- NO, NO, NO.
FORGET IT.
AH, IT'S IN THE PAST.
LET'S JOUST, THOUGH.
HA HA!
- ALL RIGHT.
[dramatic drumbeats]
- YEAH!
- AAH!
- YAH!
- YEAH!
[both screaming]
- OH...OH!
- OH-OH-OH!
wham!
[both groaning]
- IT'S-A ME, WARIO!
I'M-A GONNA WIN!
- NO!